Цих дітей Харрієт Брюс-Аннан десять років тому
забрала з вулиці в свій притулок.
"Це Вероніка, це Прісцила, це Дерек, це Ешлі,
а тут Абрагам і Джеймс-Браун".
А це Джеймс-Браун сьогодні.
Йому 27 і він - студент у Києві.
Він та інші безпритульні діти з Гани
отримали можливість здобути освіту в Україні.
Вони вивчають медицину, інформатику, право, економіку.
Завдячувати усім мають їй - Харрієт Брюс-Аннан, своїй названій мамі.
Але чому в Україні?
Тому що ця країна, як і Гана, бореться за демократію, пояснює Харрієт.
"Вони навчаються для життя.
Адже проблема корупції також у Гані велика тема.
Тут вони бачать, як люди підіймаються, аби боротися за демократію."
"Молодь в Україні не здається.
Вона змагається, стає сильною заради своєї держави.
Це вражає. У Гані ми все перекладаємо на політиків."
Українське законодавство передбачає, що після навчання
африканські студенти мають повернутися до своїх країн.
Харрієт цьому рада. Це був її план, коли вона 15 років тому
приїхала до Дюссельдорфа.
Вона працювала прибиральницею,
а зароблене відправляла до Гани, для свого сиротинця.
У Німеччині вона шукала також готових
пожертвувати для безпритульних дітей
та заснувала об’єднання "Африканські ангели".
Тривалий час діти не знали, що Харрієт доводиться мити туалети,
аби профінансувати їхнє навчання.
"Неймовірно! Коли хтось такий, як вона, змушений принижуватися
до того, щоб мити туалети, аби ми могли ходити до школи,
я просто не можу не вчитися з віддачею. І це стосується всіх нас"
І це стосується всіх нас"
"Я просто не знала, що сказати, коли довідалася.
Я би ніколи не отримала можливості піти до школи,
якби вона не мила туалети і не дбала про мене.
У мене би взагалі не було жодних шансів."
Тривалий час Харрієт не розповідала, звідки бере гроші.
Головне для неї було дати дітям освіту,
аби вони могли згодом працювати на благо своєї держави.
"Якщо ці студенти залишаться в країнах, де вони навчаються, вони будуть, як усі інші.
Але якщо вони повернуться туди, звідки приїхали,
вони можуть багато чого сподвигнути і вплинути на суспільство."
"Це моя велика мета в житті - повернутися до Гани і поліпшити там життя.
Усі скаржаться на корумповану систему.
Але в мене є кілька ідей.
Я не чекатиму, поки мені хтось запропонує роботу.
Це наше завдання - створювати робочі місця.
Хочу стати великим підприємцем."
Одну зі своїх підприємницьких ідей
жеймс підхопив тут, у Львівській майстерні шоколаду.
З любов‘ю запаковані цукерки надихають його,
він хотів би відкрити схожу мережу в Гані.
"Звідки  в Україні це какао?
Можливо, якраз з Гани.
Час щоб ми в Гані не лише вирощували боби какао, а переробляли їх.
Це дасть поштовх нашій економіці".
"У Гані вирощують не лише какао.
Ми маємо також цукор та найрізноманітніші фрукти.
Тобто ми можемо переробляти ананаси, яблука чи банани
і таким чином створювати робочі місця".
Вони багато чого навчилися в Україні.
Харрієт задоволена.
"Вони самостійні. Вони впевнені у собі.
Вони мають перспективу в житті. І вони точно знають, що робитимуть.
Це мене дуже тішить, я пишаюся ними".
Наступного року Джеймс та Річард отримають свої університетські дипломи.
А Харрієт - доказ того, що якщо безпритульним дітям дати шанс,
то вони можуть стати одними з найкращих.